et bien bonjour bienvenue dans cette
leçon toujours avec notre consultant
expert quand maître international jean
luc chabanon bouffon luque bonjour
stéphane alors aujourd'hui on va avoir
un thème tout à fait essentiel dans la
pratique du jeu d'échecs dans la
découverte du vieux d'échec
si la fameuse fourchette et oui aux
échecs comme
comme dans la mafia les qu'en dira la
vengeance est un plat qui se mange froid
et surtout avec une fourchette quoi
d'accord s'auto donc la fourchette c'est
c'est le b à ba de la tactique aux
échecs
alors ça consiste en quoi une gauchère
et ben il faut regarder une fourchette
donc c'est à dire plusieurs dans
plusieurs dents qui attaquent dans
plusieurs directions possibles
donc c'était une pièce qui est qui
attaque de pièces à la fois d'accord
multiples multiples attaques en fait
donc la double attaque voire même
tripler une triple attaque et
quelquefois oui donc là aujourd'hui nous
intéressant uniquement aux fourchettes
simple donc attaque de deux pièces à la
fois et donc la fourchette c'est
l'exercice tactique par excellence voilà
en tout cas à connaître puisque si on
veut gagner des parties évidemment il
faut bien trouver des façons souvent de
gagner du matériel et la fourchette est
le moyen idéal pour arriver à ses fins
alors on va voir plusieurs exemples de
fourchette est peut-être là la
fourchette la plus connue la plus la
plus usitée la plus célèbre est celle
dans laquelle les débutants tombe le
plus souvent mais même les grands eux
mêmes les grands maîtres
oui c'est la fameuse fourchette du
cavalier met donc les débutants on tombe
souvent dans la fourchette de cavaliers
parce que évidemment là on voit
cavaliers sur les cités alors on va
peut-être montré notre notre accord à
une proposition pour prêt à bondir jean
luc lorsque juste pour montrer cette
position mais alors c'est pas une
fouchette immédiate combat voir là
c'est une situation fait en deux temps
avec un petit piège d'ailleurs peut-être
en fait on va voir tout de suite
donc pourquoi la fourchette cavaliers
ils ont évité parce que lecavalier on
voit contrôle comme ça plein de cases
qui sera là déconnecté le cavalier qui
avec son déplacement elle pour que le
fameux déplacement elle du cavalier oui
donc là on n'arrive pas à faire à elle
avec les flèches vous fais part a donc
on voit que le cavalier un déplacement
assez particulier donc le l on veut le
faire par les cases donc là on voit l
ael virtuel fait par cavalier donc le
déplacement du cavalier est difficile à
imprimer donc dans l'esprit du néophyte
est pour ces raisons
quelquefois il oublie donc des pièges
fait par cette pièce alors moi si je si
je vois cette position qui connaît un
peu la fourchette je vais tomber dans la
tête dans la petite erreur de cette
position mais qui va quand même montrer
ce que c'est que la fourchette je vais
jouer le coup qui me paraît logique
la fameuse fourchette avec échec est
d'abord une fontenay peut y avoir
décroché sans échec confère une
fourchette on attaque de pièces il n'y a
pas d'échec et on gagne quand même une
des deux pièces en mais là il s'agit
d'une fourchette avec échec donc il n'y
a pas trop le choix pour les noirs il ya
aussi un échec au roi ici et en même
temps j'attaque le fou qui est déjà
attaqué par la tour et donc je me dis je
vais gagner une pièce alors là je fais
la fourchette voilà donc cavalier si
c'est une bonne idée évidemment c'était
c'est pour ça que j'ai mis cette
position c'est qu'il y avait un piège
donc je t'ai laissé cette fourchette
pour que tu attaques mauroy et le fou en
te disant chouette je vais gagner le fou
oui en des 8 parce que le roi va bouger
c'est ce que je me dis mais
malheureusement moi je rapproche nos
rois de ta tour et de ton cavaliers
alors moi moi aussi avec mon roi je fais
une fourchette à je fais contre
fourchette alors exactement à ta
fourchette de notre fourchette je me dis
je vais te je vais te recontré voyez
puisque je vais dire je vais prendre le
fou avec ma tour et j'attaque tattoo
récita tour prends ma tour mon cavalier
reprends ta tour avec échec alors que
j'avais j'avais prévu 7,7 contre à cette
rencontre fourchette donc tu prends le
fou avec la tour parce que si je prenais
avec le cavalier évidemment je regardais
ma tour un briquet partant alors la c5
catastrophe ça serait une catastrophe
donc tu prends donc ce fou avec la tour
mais là moi j'ai prévu un coup un terme
et un très joli qu intermédiaire c'est
tour descend sur la case b2 et je fais
échec un coup l'on voit là j'ai fait un
coup l'ont pas vu et donc comme tu l'as
pas vu là tu vas bouger avec 3 je suis
obligé et je vais prendre ton cavaliers
tôt que je n'ai pas perdu deux pièces
voilà j'ai toujours un pur moi mais j'ai
fait les bleues ont toujours un point de
plus oui mais il faut avouer que c'est
pas suffisant pour gagner
c'est pas dans cette position très chaud
en tout cas ça va être difficile alors
possible hein on peut encore gagner
cette position mais
désormais on peut gagner sa position et
puis avec des bons coups et évidemment
les mais tout reste à faire
tout reste à faire donc on va revenir à
la position initiale donc mon fourchette
c'est des combinaisons et qui dit
combinaison dit joli coup donc on va
essayer un petit peu d'éclaircir le
diagramme pour chercher le fameux joli
coup à trouver dans cette position donc
là stéphane je suis sûr que tu vas
trouver le jeu dans sa position
oui alors évidemment donc si je me dis
bon mais ça marche pas mais par contre
je me dis j'ai toujours cette
possibilité de fourchette ici voilà est
donc en fait je peux faire une petite
simplification intermédiaire la fameuse
simplification donc en fait donc je vais
et bien fait sacrifier ma tout voilà
contre le fou tout simplement
et là je gagnais une pièce est là donc
si tu me reprends pas bien j'ai gagné
une pièce
donc tu n'as pas yannick y est pas
encore pour l'instant tu donnes une
pièce pour l'instant je donne une pièce
de jeu j'ai changé voilà tu fais
chauffer ce qu'on appelle un sacrifice
de qualité du béton contre un fou
conclut prend le fou et là évidemment
les noirs si une si la tour bouge sur
n'importe quel cas c'est la tour b 8e
bougeant b6 les noirs perdre le fou
voilà est probablement la partie puisque
avec avec donc finalement avec un
cavalier une tour est un pion contre une
tour c'est bien ça va être très
difficile bon on peut pas empêcher le
pion d'aller à dame sauf à donner à tour
contre le pion et voire même le pion aux
cavaliers mais en tout cas il restera
touré roi pour gagner exactement donc
surtout reprend des 8 on est obligé de
prendre la tour voilà et maintenant j'ai
ma fameuse fourchette la nasa il est à
pluton échec intermédiaire parce que
c'est moi qui fait échec et la tap une
fois exactement donc la ruf et la
fameuse fourchette lecavalier qui
attaquent le roi et la tour le roi de
boucher et le cavaly prend la tour là on
se retrouve avec un cavalier un pion
contre un roi à grenoble donc un
cavalier un pion contre un roi
alors je crois qu'il faut se reporter
tout simplement
au final pions roi contre roy on voit
comment il faut faire essayer pour
gagner et on verra que lecavalier
permettra de gagner le temps nécessaire
à transformer la position mais le
galvanise toute façon il n'y a pas de
problème ça gagne face à gan facilement
il faut pas perdre le cas bien
évidemment mais pas par des pensions va
amener le plus moderne et après obama tu
es voilà donc première fourchette donc
là la fourchette 2 cavaliers donc mais
aux échecs ce qui est important de
savoir c'est qu'il n'y a pas que des
fourchettes de cavaliers oui il n'ya pas
des prochaines carrière on va peut-être
passer la position suivante on va passer
à la position suivante alors tout de
suite c'est magique positions suivantes
donc la position suivante celle ci est
donc aux échecs
il y a aussi des fourchettes de pions de
tour de dame de fou de toutes les pièces
qu'on veut une fourchette ces attaques
et de pièces en même temps donc en
menaçant une pièce elle d'objets mais on
mange l'autre voilà c'est tout simple on
mange on prend manger c'est peut-être un
piano bar tard on va voir que la
fourchette dans cette position là nous
permet de faire une petite combinaison
qui est pas forcément bonne mais qu'il
est en tout cas qui est à considérer
evra samaras au fait que la fourchette
existe exactement c'est à dire que dans
cette position je pourrais te poser la
question stéphane est ce que je peux
prendre le pion sur la case de 5,6 je
réfléchis à court terme jeudi mais non
puisque si tu prends le 5 je te reprends
le cavalier tu me reprends le cavalier
donc là dans cette position avec mon
cavalier on pourrait croire que je vais
faire une grave erreur puisque ton
cavalier va m'en va prendre mon cavalli
sur la case of 5
il apprend que la vallière le 5 mais là
j'ai tout prévu
c'est à dire que j'ai prévu une fameuse
fourchette 2 pions là ça sera pas
cavalier ce sera un pion qui va faire la
fourchette
donc j'avance manquions de deux cases et
j'attaque tout fou et en cavalier donc
alors dans ce cas là mais je suis coincé
je repère la pièce tu repères la pièce
voilà autant prendre un pion au passage
tu peux prendre avec le fou ou ramener
temps fou sur cette case hors jeu
le pion dit soit tu prends un pion comme
ça soit je prends mes cheveux cavaliers
oui plusieurs possibilités où tu prends
ce pion avec lecavalier
alors on va on va d'abord regarder avec
le fou si tu prends avec le fou moi je
récupère ma pièce tout simplement je
n'ai pas gagné de matériel mais j'en ai
pas perdu
voilà ce qui la partie continue enfin
navarre dit continuer pas davantage
ensuite avoir fait cette fourchette
alors bien jusque là je voulais juste
démontrer que beaucoup étaient possibles
voilà et je crois que j'y suis arrivé si
tu prends du cavalier c'est la même
chose je prends le fou bon là indique le
pion donc le pion en d4 qui est bien
qu'on dira qu'il ya bien réussi sa
mission c'est-à-dire attaqué deux pièces
une pièce s'en va on prend l'autre
donc c'est le la thématique principale
de la fourchette très bien alors on va
peut-être passer à la position suivante
on va passer à la position suivante la
puissance suivant la position suivante
on sent que c'est une fourchette de fou
alors hop voilà donc on va revenir en
arrière encore donc dans cette position
c'est aux blancs de jouer et là c'est
une combinaison
c'est une combinaison donc pour
l'instant il ya à peu près à égalité
matérielle on voit que la tour en b 4
est assez active puisque l attaque le
pion c4 et le pion à 4 elle veut des
noms j'ai donc si avec les blancs je ne
trouve pas un coup miracle
eh bien je risque d'être dans une
situation délicate parce qu'il faut
noter c'est que mais en fait ce fou ici
là il
il est bien pour l'instant quand même
parce que il attaque ici on est faible
il n'est pas défendu oui et mais surtout
peut-être à noter la chose qui doit
frapper tout de suite c'est la
possibilité qu en fait toutes ces cases
ici toutes ces pièces son surclassement
exactement donc évidemment dans ce qui
dans le jeu tactique il faut être très
observateur donc on a un fou dans une
position un fou de cases noires sur un
15 2 3 oui il faut regarder tout ce qui
est sûr caisse noire
il faut garder les diagonales ou le fou
peut aller là
je sais pas comment on fait les cases
rouges voilà que c'est comme ça là on
est une diagonale les des gones à a3 et
fuite qui rouge
oui il le fou peut aller sur cet
événement pour l'instant il ya emprise
du fliers
pour l'instant il est en reprise c'est
vrai que là si on prenait le fou si on
prenait le pion avec le fou le fou
mangerait de fouet ont permis une pierre
une pièce mais peut-être qu'il ya une
solution
alors moi ça me fait penser mon cher
jean luc à la même petite combinaison
combien de voir au début c'est à dire
une simplification intermédiaire je
pense encore une fois un sacrifice de
qualité tout repart en foot puisque ça
élimine le défenseur de ce pion là pour
l'instant j'ai pris et les noirs pas
tellement le choix en fait dans cette
position puisqu'il faut reprendre la
pièce prises pour nous c'est clair que
si par exemple les noirs cette position
prenez le pion c4 bon ma tour est
attaqué par le roi je vais prendre le
pion j'ai gagné donc j'ai gagné une
pièce il gagna j'ai un fou de plus on
dire la toile a tué un tour et moi j'ai
une tour et on peut même dire que c'est
gagnant c'est gagnant donc le coup
obligé après tout on prend en fout c'est
de prendre avec le roi on est obligé de
prendre la tournée j'ai regretté la
pièce est maintenant l'astuce donc là
maintenant la fameuse fourchette échecs
et ses fourchettes
voilà on voit très bien on va très bien
que le roi est attaqué et au couchant
groulx et bien la tour malheureusement
va se faire
gobé par le fou laissant un avantage
décisif aux blancs oui la tour b 4 qui
se fait gober est donc finalement donc
cette ce fameux petit couteau province
est qui permet d'exploiter donc les
faiblesses qui avait sur cette diagonale
à trois fuites donc la finale la
fourchette avec un fou c'est possible
donc maintenant nous allons peut-être
essayer de voir une fourchette de tours
alors on va voir une peut-être autre
jour revenir l'arrière voilà on va
revenir dans cette position là c'est
tout c'est tout blanc de jouer
alors si on goûte le matériel on voit
que les noirs ont un cabinet est un fou
contre une torah pions et de pions et
c'est à peu près équilibrés alors ce
qu'on a tout de suite dans cette
position
ses dirigeants lui c'est que le fou de
cases noires ici en fait très peu de
cases et sa disposition
parce que en fait ce cavalier semble un
peu maladroitement placé puisqu'il
bouche le fou sur cette diagonale
oui c'est bien vu et derrière ses pions
ici contrôler les cases noires donc le
fou ne peut pas aller
la touriste y contrôler les deux
dernières cases du fou donc se fout en
fait n'aurait en cas d'attaqué qu'une
seule classe de repli c'est cette cette
classe b si si si seule case de repli du
fou s'ils étaient attaqués et je peux
noter que s'il était du coup sûr cette
case eh bien ils seraient sur la même
travers ce que l'on mois et demi donc
sujet à une attaque de la touraine donc
je pense que ces remarques cela doit
suffire à trouver finalement la petite
combinaison qui permet de placer une
fourchette décisive
donc là on va donc remettre la position
on va enlever les flèches et on va donc
chercher le coup qui va forcer au x 5 à
venir sur la classe b 6 donc voilà on
pourrait imaginer durable et et je vais
l'attaquer avec la tour
ah oui mais la grave erreur puisque le
cavalier ans et 7,1 royal cavaliers qui
pourrait prendre mais aussi le fou en
fait tu pourrais aussi aller sur cette
case donc ça remplit
l'objectif évidemment la prise du
cavalier est encore plus décisive mais
ça ne remplit pas l'objectif donc on
peut pas bouger la tour donc est-ce
qu'il resterait pas un goût alors c'est
facile parce qu'elle prend beaucoup de
pièces
il n'y a pas beaucoup de pièces il faut
y aller de l'avant et donc mes quatre
des glaces revoilà attaque le fou et on
voit que ce four n'a pas de gaz puisque
le pion méga très protégé voilà donc la
france a aussi le fou b4 s'il le faut à
5 prend le pion p4 on retrouve avec le
pion et tours
epyon contre cavaliers ça gagne face tu
gagnes très facilement non pas par du
plomb mais par le pion on va amener le
roi on va mener le roi des votes le roi
noir est coupée en plus par la tour ce
qui veut dire que sur b4 on est obligé
de jouer foulée six objets et là et là
ça y est donc le fameux coup qu'on
disait tout à l'heure up échec
voilà avec la tour noire est ainsi hop
voilà échec et le fou est terminée donc
il faut le fait où il faut et perdu par
exemple on peut protéger du cavalier on
peut protéger on mange le fond je le
fous et voilà c'est terminé
parce que ce pion il va aller à dame
tout seul pas trop comment les noirs
mais n'en peuvent les changer on peut
même envisager de sacrifier la tour
contre le cavaly puisque roy doc contre
heureux gagnant ça gagne facilement très
facilement et ça enlèverait les
fourchettes que pour réussir les noirs
c'est vrai ça va on sait jamais une
fille en cordes sait jamais on peut
s'entraîner en toute façon sa position
mais il a vu la fourchette donc permet
d'obtenir un net avantage notamment
table alors maintenant donc fourchette
de taux fourchette de fourchette de
cavaliers fourchette de pions il reste
là crochète deux dames alors qu'on va
regarder sur cette position alors sur la
position nous avons l'écran donc on a
donc une dame contre une tour est un fou
alors la dame et on rappelle que la dame
extrêmement puissante puisque le
contrôle tout ce qui donne à halle et
aussi tout ce qui est tu traverses et
colonnes donc le nombre de cases qu'on
produit par une dame est tout à fait
étonnant tout à fait énorme alors la
théorie d'une finale comme ça quand une
dame joue contre une
une tour est un fou c'est que c'est plus
ou moins équilibrés on imagine dans
cette position que la tour arrive sur la
case l7 par exemple mais dans cette
position de la tour arrive son rs27 il
ya blocus
il y à un blocus le roi blanc adverse ne
pourra pas franchir ce blocus est le roi
noir donc ce rendement ne pourra pas
dépasser donc cette colonne f
oui est il donc le roi noir sera en
sécurité une promenade mater il restera
près du fou pour contrôler une fougue
qui contrôle lui-même la tour voilà donc
autant dire que dans cette position donc
si on enlève les flèches
il y a il y a urgence il faut trouver
tout de suite la solution pour moi c'est
gagner sinon c'est nul alors pour gagner
il faut soit grappiller le fou puisque
si on gagne ou on peut gagner soit piqué
la tour alors moi je me dis
effectivement quitté la tour moi je veux
tout de suite une fourchette fou luxe et
d'un suit donc la f8 j'attaque à la fois
le roi et la tour dont je gagne une tour
donc damas fuite c'est une bonne idée
mais il ya une parade à blâmer suite qui
attaquent le roi et la tour
malheureusement c'est pareil partout
rejet cette voie là je peux ramener la
tour pour à l'échec et donc tu peux plus
prendre la tour puisque j'ai là je
perdrais la dame voilà donc ça marche
pas alors les fourchettes de vincent
intéressante parce que c'est vrai que la
dame est l'un des placements tellement
incroyable que il faut quand même
regarder beaucoup de cases et la tente
en tente à trouver une fourchette mais
il y avait une parade
il faut trouver la case précise et dans
cette position-là cases précises le bon
coup pour cette raison le coup gagnant
ces dames h quatre échecs 1 de l'autre
côté
voilà le coup gagnant hélas la tourbe
personne car cause il est là dans cette
position-là tour ne peut pas
s'interposer ou peuvent interposés le
fou voilà on peut jouer le faux h5 mais
je prends la tour dans tous les cas la
tour est perdu et là par contre dame
contrefous ainsi face il faut ramener le
roi voilée en mettre au moins deux
facilement d'un cotre fou ça gagne si on
jouera g7 c'est la même chose on prend
la tour sur échec et ça gagne facilement
puisque là maintenant une dame contrat
fou c'est facile donc là on a vu
fourchette de fourchette de dames
donc on a vu toutes les pièces il nous
reste finalement la fourchette suprême
donc la fourchette la plus connue aux
échecs donc là pour représenter cette
fourchette
eh ben j'ai choisi une partie célèbre
donc j'ai choisi une partie qui a été
jouée par le 9e championnat de champion
du monde des échecs à savoir tigran
petrosyan donc la champion du monde de
l'ère soviétique et j'ai choisi ce qu'on
appelle la fourchette royal de
petrossian donc champion du monde de
1960 à 1963 et 66 et 63 jusqu'à 1959
donc voilà qui avait perdu 109 contre
boris spassky après l'avoir battu à 66,1
scénique et qui avait battu beauté
unique voilà et qui avait battu bobigny
oui qui avait pas de suppôt de vidic
et d'ailleurs bobigny à chaque fois
avaient droit à un match revanche mais
contre tigran tête au sol il n'a pas eu
le droit sans match revanche c'est à
dire qu'il a récupéré son titre face à
tyson of pas face avec smith l'ofs mais
face à petrossian il n'y avait plus la
possibilité du match revanche est cette
fois donc il a abandonné la course au
titre mondial parce qu'à son âge il
avait neigé plus l'énergie pour moment
c'est oui et puis bonne taille botanique
et comme diagonale était finalement à a
consacré finalement la fin de sa
carrière à l'enseignement du jeu
puisqu'il avait une école à moscou et
donc c'était c'était c'était le
professeur d'échec
en place à moscou alors voyons sur cette
cette partie alors moi j'ai une idée
évidemment c'est une combinaison
fantastique on va la voir tout de suite
mais alors j'ai misé tout de suite je me
dis mais voilà j'ai trouvé l'idée parce
que lecavalier ici c'est la pièce
magique pour faire des fers d des
fourchettes
alors je me dis si le roi noir bouger
ici je pourrai faire cavaler prendre
pour échec et ensuite je prendrai la
dame aura ça serait la razzia
oui si oblin de jouer un pour l'instant
est bon ça serait pas mal je me dis mais
alors si le roi noir prenait ici ce
serait pareil cavaliers prend pour échec
et que les pandas alors comment je
pourrais faire
est-ce que je peux mais oui mais oui
j'ai trouvé une idée mais déjà très
attention si on regarde la position on
peut aussi se poser la question qu'est
ce qui se passe sur quels contours
oui à perdre un tour mais sur alors sur
calais prend un tour je pense que le
joueur
petrosyan l'ancien champion du monde a
eu peur de dante un échec
il a eu peur que l'adversaire tente d
échec perpétuelle c'est à dire que
l'allemagne aura sans doute en échec par
petro lalla dante 1 qui attaquent le roi
charles par exemple sur fou ici et bien
tout simplement refaire un échec ici il
y aurait beaucoup d'échecs il y aurait
beaucoup d'échecs
ce serait un peu difficile la partie
n'est pas encore fini et
le champion du monde veut terminer avec
classe donc il veut trouver le meilleur
coup et à moi j'ai une idée c'est que je
me dis voilà d'1h huit échecs
parce que si sur ce coup étonnante donne
la d'annecy le reprend et bien je
récupère tout la tour avec échec et
fourchettes royal voilà le roi prend
dame sacrifice de dames de déviation
certifie de déviation car les prend pour
échec ou un g7
et ensuite et voilà j'ai deux pièces de
plus alors là c'est clairement gagnant
voyez là c'est tout à fait gagnant mais
il ya quand même une parade sur des
matches huit échecs c'est que le roi
n'est pas obligé de prendre la dame
il peut fuir il peut fuir par exemple
sur la case g61 g62 furent sur laquelle
g6 et on n'a pas encore gagné si on fait
par exemple dame g8 pour cette position
échec pour piquer la tour ben on peut
par le parent et l'échec et puis voilà
et puis là on est y a plus il faut tout
recommencer pour commencer donc ça donc
ça suffit pas malade malgré la beauté du
coup ça suffit pas alors que tu n'étais
pas très loin de la solution
j'étais pas de one piece mission à nom
alors je vois pas du tout peur si dame
marche pas là je vois pas du tout du
tout du tout imagine un petit peu donc
là le problème c'est que
on était on avait la parade roi g6 alors
il faudrait trouver une solution pour
que le roi ne soit obligé de prendre la
dame en ma chute
c'est un peu compliqué mais je pense que
tu vas trouver alors je crois que j'ai
trouvé jean lieu puisque tu vas me
donner l'idée je le crois que j'ai
trouvé
il s'agirait du coup qui a l'air très
surprenant fou prend pions échec
voilà donc la fourchette de fou mais on
pourrait appeler ça une fourchette
kamikazes puis c'est le fou se
sacrifient aux attaques l'euro 1
j'attaque la dame met effectivement en
fait en fous mon fou et est en prise et
il n'est pas protégé mais mais mais
comme j'ai calculé mon coude avant qu'on
mais je viens de voir
c'est pour ça que je suis confiant pour
louis escoula donc là c'est un sacrifice
camille s à une fourchette kamikazes
je ne peut vraisemblablement pas bouger
mon roi puisque je perdrais la dame
donc je dois prendre le fou avec la dame
obligé ça a beaucoup c'est vrai si
obligé puisque sinon d'âmes perdues ce
serait fini et maintenant je peux vous
ne va rien tu peux plus tu échappes et
angers sismondi gens lui eva l'institut
t'échappe angie 6 pouces je prends la
dame et là j'ai gagné un parti
facilement alors tu prends la dame sur
ce que l'on appelle une enfilade
mais au final alors leur fils at ça sera
ça pourrait être le thème d'une autre
leçon vous dire qu'après son tactique
mais là bon c'est la fourchette
alors c'est à dire là si on jouera g6 on
explique bien la dame prend la dame par
un field par enfilade et on a quand même
une position gagnante ou d'un coup donc
après damas chouette échec cette fois on
est obligé de prendre la dame on est
obligé de prendre la dame est là donc on
va un petit peu faire un petit peu un
petit arrêt sur image pour regarder la
position il ya une fourchette royal mais
c'est vous la fourchette royal c'est la
fourchette entre le roi et la dame avec
ramassage le matériel avec
obligatoirement gagne la dame après oui
ni ramassage du matériel en plus ou pas
sans conséquence puisque la dalle c'est
quand même la pièce la plus fort c'est
assez énorme de sacrifier tous tous est
tout ce matériel fou et dames pour avait
une position où maintenant si les mains
sales
oui il a tout donné pour finalement
jouer la fourchette de rejeter ce lézard
georges et royal avec prise de pièces
c'est difficile de faire une position on
ramasse autant de matériel en deux
groupes il faudrait presque la tour soit
remplacé cette tour la forêt parce que
ça soit une dame
oui ça c'est encore mieux ça serait
aisément ramasser ça serait le bout
idéal mais déjà c'est que c'est presque
en deux coups c'est le plus de matériel
qu'on peut ramasser et puis c'est une
position incroyable pour une partie de
compétition échec et donc c'est la
fameuse fourchette royal après enfilade
voilà donc un roi en échec doit bouger
c'est obligé ces règlements
ça c'est énorme donc oui exactement on a
tout fait vorsah 3 jan
hélas après 3 bougez et ben cavaliers
prend table en fin d'année après là
c'est gagnant donc là c'est simplement
on va jouer ensuite qu'à valider cette
ramasser ce pion et ensuite c'est très
facile on va simplement reculer le
cavalier et ensuite avec le roi on va
prendre ce pion ici puisque le roi noir
va être obligé de contrôler ce pion ici
et moi ne pourra pas le danger ils
projet rien manger puisque les cavaliers
le protègera ont nié par exemple on peut
on juger quelqu'un coûts en achetant
quelques on va jouer l'adversaire se
rapproche du cavalier échecs ont fait
échec
il vient encore en corse au chalet leroy
bien là on prend le pion par le roi
essaye de se rapprocher ouais on vient
là j'achète le roi se rapprochent
méchamment mais l'année on pousse ce
qu'on voit là c'est terminé
et si le roi prendre cavaliers mais là
on va faire date on va à dame
hélas est un gagnant très facilement et
donc comme le roi ne peut pas prendre ne
pourra jamais prendre le cavalier le roi
blanc dans cette position devrait
s'amuser
il va se rapprocher il va déjà bougé le
pion qui va manger ce pion et après il
va tout simplement sera vert jaune et
son temps pour accompagner ceux qui ont
valeur jusqu'à damas puisque adam il va
se faire idée du cavalier éventuelles
donc voilà un beau petit communication
pour pour terminer cette fourchette
royal
alors pour ceux qui sont encore
débutants
viens entraîné voit l'année cette finale
en jouant mais même contre vous-même
contre l'ordinateur pourquoi pas et elle
est facile à gagner
aller jusqu'aux maths en vous aidant
peut être des leçons sur comment gagner
avec des rois et on contre roy ou qui
est équivalent au roi et dames contre
roy une fois qu'on aura fait d'un avec
le pion entraînez-vous à bien comprendre
le plan ici qui consiste à ramasser
d'abord le pion dangereux des noirs pour
ensuite aller faire une dame simple ans
et voilà un plan de finale en simple
mais c'est un plan et voilà comprenait
les petites subtilités c'est intéressant
en tout cas là on a vu peut-être un des
plus beaux est devenue une des plus
belles combinaisons on peut le dire du
de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs fait
partie grande prétention à noter que
tigran petrossian a fait une combinaison
semblables semblables roman semblables
face à boris spassky dans son
championnat du monde de 1966 la position
était un peu différente mais c'était la
même combinaison de jouer des matches
huit échecs forçant le roi noir à
prendre la dame est ensuite fait une
double double de récupération avec
fourchette c'était une partie aussi très
très célèbre donc c'était le roi de la
fourche at t le roi de la fourchette
donc c'est un joueur qu elle est
jeu d'échecs donné beaucoup d'appétit
tout à fait voilà eh bien je fais tomber
mauroy terminé pour cette leçon sur la
fourchette à bientôt sur diagonale à
luxembourg jean luc au revoir stéphane